I gotta get out of here hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to my cardigan I dug it out of the
closet to be with me during my sick time
so that I would not be afraid and or
cold in the face of the zombie
apocalypse okay also welcome back to
this game so if when if if and when we
last left off I was in the face of
annihilation death was be falling me
from every circumstance around me or
whatever
blue herb mud not do anything with that
no that's right okay
Oh lights hello today do it's beautiful
okay I need to get rid of some [ __ ] I
need to put this in there because the
film is already there there's a case in
the film area I can do that
this I'm gonna put away this gem I'm
gonna put away cuz I don't know if I
need that this crank I'm gonna keep this
electric parts I'm gonna keep the key
I'm gonna put away Matilda Matilda why
are you not worried not done
there's Matilda alright take that out
combined with that alright put away this
[ __ ]
samurai edge whatever that means no one
cares put that there I've got bullets
that garden looks so cool it's gonna be
legit - legit even - quit I put this
there I'm gonna put this away
um and then I think no no no alright
maybe the kid I'm gonna guess that the
check mark does mean that it's dunzo
because that would make a lot of sense
right
that would make a ton of sense okay so
I've got my - you what - daddy I've got
maturity yeah yeah Matilda yeah alright
hello I'll take you yes please hello
perfect love you
all right what have we got here Oh mag
ammo for my Magnum dong I don't have
this thing just gonna die come on ski
all right and what's this electrical
okay whatever all right so I got another
electrical part but I don't know what
that's to but I should probably keep it
on me I'm gonna put this way I'm gonna
put my Magnum dong away cuz it's
disturbing people and I've got an idea
what what would a green and a blue do is
probably a waste of it but you know I'm
kind of curious if this combined with
this Oh what does that do
remove any toxins and destroy restore
slate it also there was an option to
blend it with that and I feel like that
would have been a really good blend but
now I've got a bunch of plans and that's
good for me wait everybody hold up your
dicks hang on hold on a second it's
about to get ham wild here because we're
all [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Oh fully heals restores plus it reduces
damage station guards again oh [ __ ]
that's nice I think that is really good
probably no all right I can get two of
those good I don't know is that good I
don't know it's probably good yeah yeah
little baby let's do it let's do two
yes I think great that's awesome
probably alright I got those good great
okay so now that I got that let me save
cuz I just want to revoke ibly do
whatever I just did and then we can
finally move on with our godforsaken
lives where am I even oh [ __ ] okay oh
[ __ ] Oh what did I just do I can turn
around
that's such a useful skill I think I
don't know whatever hello
okay so that's where I came from nice
floor mop okay so I it was it was
brought to my attention not by anyone
around there but by myself that I may
need to take just a teensy tinsy poon
see more time carefully going through
everything in this place cuz I don't
want to miss what I don't want to miss a
thing oh oh wait a minute hey wait a
minute wait a minute I wish I had my
knife I think I remember where my knife
is when I was editing the first episode
I remember where my knife was cut
post-game what what the Apple come on
I'm just gonna blow by this guy yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] oh God
okay put that in there all right we're
good and it's gonna open back nice yes
please I was begging for a knife oh how
could I not spray you oh oh I thought I
boarded that up I thought I okay
whatever you know what it's fine because
one of the dudes in here had my knife
whoa whoa whoa whoa you you've got my
knife
oh okay all right good
I mean not good I have not been doing
good for quite some time but good hey
buddy
guess who's back friend friend I forget
your name friend Larry or something I
dan oh oh oh that's that's real sad
Marvin no ah well you know Marvin okay
you know Marvin I I don't need to shoot
you so I don't know why would Marvin um
mmm Marvin okay you know Marvin it's
okay I'm gonna let you be you're gonna
be my buddy we're gonna be pals
we're gonna be the best of friends you
and me Marvin the apocalypse together
that's how we roll baby we don't let
each other down we build each other up
okay what am i doing again where am I
going I forget where I'm going I need to
get to Joe I need to get to the the film
development area which was down here
maybe probably not
I'm gonna guess not but I'm gonna go for
it anyway here we go here we go baby oh
yeah you Lichtenstein there wait the
living room bedroom I had no idea
hello linens yes please gunpowder I'll
take some Linens
anybody else for the linens ooh a safe
okay let me take some time as I figure
this out all right
let's do this okay you're there oh oh
yeah first second BAM Oh doh doh doh doh
doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh I
get a new fanny pack I'm super excited
that's gonna be so good is it the only
thing in here I guess it's the only
thing that I really need okay so I need
to go develop this film whatever that
means I don't know what benefit that
would be no how are you how are you I'm
fine thank you
all right farewell you guys are doing so
good I am so proud of all of you guys
here where was this Phil
Moe develop Oh area I've completely
forgotten it was down here yeah meals
down here hey hey hey listen listen
listen listen I'm gonna kick your ass
down the stairs if I could kick Oh your
hand they can't do nothing you ain't
gonna do nothing nothing no no no why
can't I knife anybody can I knife
anybody this is a bunch of [ __ ] okay
well apparently the knife technique
doesn't work did my knife just break no
it didn't break it's being a piece of
[ __ ] that's what it's gonna be or I'll
take this I'm fine I'm better now all
the sudden magically alright whatever I
need you better then I need to get a lot
better at that ok so film here alright
use this here 3f locker DCM that's so
nice
ok thank you DCM cool that's it
alright well ok that's good it's a good
thing it's probably a good thing it's a
good thing it's a good thing it's
definitely a good thing there's probably
some reward at the end of the game if
you don't use too many saves but at this
point I'm so what no don't don't
you're done there you go that's what I
thought
god I slice that guy up so good what was
that mysterious strange noise that I
heard no whatever I forgotten what it
was already what was it DCM all right
d.c
perfect easy what I get mag ammo for
that Magnum gun I got ya alright so
where was the weapon locker room
was it down here he was down here
somewhere down here anyway
did you get back up you better not have
gotten back up your hand is gone why
didn't you even have any opportunity
ah oh oh [ __ ] oh no no no no no no okay
come on come on come on come on mammy
mammy I want some yeah yeah yeah that's
right that's right
I probably shouldn't waste so much ammo
and stop jiggling
can you stop jiggling stop jiggling it
stop it stop yeah good okay whatever
either way no no no no no no Donna you a
weapon locker room was oh I think you
you know what I got backup knife to [ __ ]
all right there we go
can I have my knives back both of them
please I get both the knives thank you
thank you I didn't need to do that but I
did it anyway okay here we go
and replacement key I am okay so what
was it it was um 103 gets a new knife
106 gets more film which is always good
why did I get that before I don't know
to do anything for by which okay no see
103 and then 203 I think is the other
one that I need okay 203 yeah baby yeah
baby yeah baby yeah Bobby okay
caboose key oh ho [ __ ] another I love my
life I love my life I love my life I
have no ammo but I love my life I think
I think it only loses a bunch of
durability if you use it in self-defense
come Memorial come amore iam I could
have gotten that at any time I'm such an
idiot
I probably should have gotten then a
long time ago whatever back to the film
development area homos geek who's here
anybody doesn't matter I'm out of here
see ya nerd
all right hobo's key all right whatever
guy use commemorative photo I I already
knew that I knew that I knew that's not
news your are not news all right fun I'm
gonna put away my good knife and I'm
gonna use these two down I'm gonna put
away my good ammo do I have any
gunpowder I can get some shotgun shells
which I'm probably gonna do yeah I'm
gonna do that let's do that combine that
with that and that wasn't as many as I
was hoping for but at least I have
something to defend myself with which
now I need to be more careful about my
ammo I'm very bad about ammo so I gotta
use my knife okay where am i off to next
what did I need I have a diamond key
that's a heart key that's not what I
need diamond key for a diamond man
diamond key there's a grenade in there
apparently
what else did I get cranked cranky yank
I've got a crank I know where the crank
goes I think I know what I know yeah I
know where the crank goes yeah I know
where the crank goes okay I know where
the crank goes I know where the crank
goes it's a bit of it out of the way but
I know where the crank goes no wait no
I'm dumb it was this way I'm dumb Marvin
okay see Marvin hey buddy hey buddy
buddy buddy
okay bye okay cranky yank I've got a
cranky and I've got a Yankee let's put
the cranky in the Yankee and let's see
what happens there we go
now that is what I am talking about now
that is something of which I am
discussing currently now that is in fact
what I am talking to hello oh you can I
get you with this that's a heart one I
don't have a heart I have a heart at all
oh okay
creepy up or creepy down I'm gonna go
with creepy up I'm gonna go with creepy
up but uh I'm ready my knife is about to
explode but I'm ready for you oh okay
I'll take this board yes please I'm
gonna move this around just so I can get
this out seems like the diamond was only
wore the diamond was only one one key I
guess you could have easily missed it so
something there oh thank you for that
that's helpful
I guess I'll finally Jesus some bullets
maybe Mathilde isn't as good because
Mathilde uses so many bullets cuz rapid
fire [ __ ] probably because of the
extended stock or something like that
alright which way am I going balcony re
storage room I like the sound of the
storage room could be some so [ __ ]
who's there
who is there who's hiding
no no no is that a crank do I need this
yeah I need this large gear all right
Irv ik that's so drippy oh hey
all right why am I here why do you guys
drip so much why are you guys so goopy
you you're just waiting in ambush by
what I'm leaving huh okay all right I
got that I'm out of here I'm out I'm out
baby I'm gonna find out where this goes
Hey sibel kitty it's so romantic more
blue herb I don't know what blue Irv
would do if you combined two blue herbs
you can't you can't do it you can't
combine two blue herbs that's just
ridiculous why would you even try to do
that all right here we go whoa oh no
please I'm begging you
not like this my grand oh I'll never be
able to get back up ever again oh boy
that that's fun yeah that was fun why'd
that happen I don't know what is this
hey can I have this oh oh right can I
just keep yanking on until it breaks off
I'm gonna do it one more time if doesn't
break off then then I'm gonna give up on
this pipe dream you get it all right
okay
all right bullets yes please I need
those from a gun all right what else is
up here
some nice benches I don't know whether
bright red like that I don't know where
I am in general anyway where am i oh I'm
on some kind of a roof yes so this is
some water valve lever that goes
somewhere where does this go
oh no I need to put out the fire
Oh with the water you think that the
rain would do it but apparently not all
right whatever
there's just loose lead oh okay all
right well that's not helpful for
anybody all right I'll go down then I
don't know where this is gonna lead me
but hopefully oh it's probably gonna
leave me we're gonna we be back inside
out yes
all right yeah oh yeah that door that's
a good door I like the sounds that are
coming from behind that door that door
my favorite door oh really yeah okay
that's all it was just a bunch of
douches okay whatever whatever whatever
let me let me ring around the rosey him
because I don't have time to deal with
you I don't have time to at war the ammo
to deal with both of you oh you're quick
oh you're skippity doo-dah quick are
come on skip to my Lou what are you
really
really oh you forgotten about me already
okay all right then I see how it is yeah
okay yeah yeah okay yeah yeah you're
very scary very scary they just turn
around oh my god
ha well that was a lunge that was quite
a lunge buddy final lunge
hey can I get you from here oh hey buddy
are you doing hey hey come on up here
hey come are you hey you know I was just
messing with you before I'm messing with
you here come over hey how you doing
okay you forgotten about me already all
right
[Applause]
oh ho well that's handy all right well
whatever I wasted a few bullets and I
think my knife is dunzo but it's all for
the good at least I got by him even
though my original intention was not to
waste any ammo and then I expressly did
waste ammo but that's ok because it's
not you know you don't always get what
you want what is this it's a
left-to-right thing it's uh it's a
right-to-left lever it just that's all
it does it's all it needs to do hello ah
ah what is that is that a legging a boot
is that a legging a boot or is that just
a sock I think that's a leg in a booth
all right well good old leg in a boot
where am i boiler room ok
hello oh that's nice ok great I've got a
lot of mixed herbs yeah not sure what to
do with all them but I've got them cool
great great cool great and cool great
and cool uh-oh someone lose a key with a
club key the club yes please let me
store these because I don't need them
anymore I don't know what I'm gonna do
with the gear but I'm gonna hold on to
it until I can figure out what to do
with it but now I've got the club key I
don't know what to do with the club key
but I got the club key so that's nice
alright good this is great I'm happy
about this maybe I don't know I I hate
that I have to declare my happiness to
the heavens like that but I think I'm
happy about this so now that I got that
and that went right to left now I'm
pretty sure I can put out the dome now
I'm pretty sure I can put out the fire
cuz it'll probably do some yeah it'll go
through the left pipe and not the right
pipe right okay and then this will break
off this is probably gonna break off
when it finally works yeah or not
oh okay well that was fun all right now
I can go around it probably get back in
the building maybe go actually down
instead oh oh I know better I know
better I know better I know better
oh boy I I know better okay listen
listen whoa you're fast
now run faster run faster yeah I know
better I know better I know better than
to try to fight you I know better I know
better I know better batter better I
know better I know better
whoa this is very bumpy I don't know I'm
gonna go out here oh [ __ ] this he just
keep coming
does he just keep coming
they just keep coming oh no um okay well
uh huh Oh Marvin Marvin help Marvin
help Marvin Marvin help Marvin Marvin I
could use some help
Marvin please Marvin oh god where am I
going
I'm trying to find the club room I don't
remember where the club room was oh wait
no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude okay um
if I hot ah [ __ ] if I hide he'll never
get me yeah that's right yeah
oh yeah which way am I going you don't
even know you don't even know man good
even oh no aah
why am I trying to get to the club room
it's just gonna end up in my desk cuz
I'm just gonna get cornered in it and
I'm gonna die I don't know why that's
all I know I've got the club key here I
go so what I'm doing Oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh you missed you missed you
missed you missed look I got a crank
I got a Craig Craig didn't there's some
gunpowder I'll just go NAB that real
quick no you in key doink uh yup few ink
oh [ __ ] don't know you don't wanna oh oh
you're not who I thought you were okay
you're fine kinda not not really fine
but you're fine okay does that mean the
big guy's gone almost sooner that means
big guys gone but I'm not gonna assume
that lictors gone I'm just gonna run
this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I thought I
boarded that up
why why would you do things such as like
is that okay I'm gonna put a cut through
here what is this record of events I
didn't even know about the events that
happened okay I'm gonna go through here
cut through here all good baby
oh god damn it I'm with the wrong guy
please don't let me die I don't know why
I went the wrong way I went the wrong
way I went the wrong way I went the
wrong way I thought I was smart it turns
out I am NOT I went the wrong way
oh no no how no how where are you where
is he where is he I don't know where he
is
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay well that's that's not good um I'm
probably gonna run straight into oh [ __ ]
boss boss [ __ ] oh hey buddy hey hey pal
listen listen listen just hold on to
yourselves
just hold on where am I I don't know
please no please don't let the nightmare
the nightmare oh please no please oh uh
yeah look at Ricky not Ricky yeah this
is a trick there's a trick I'm tricking
you
I would trick you I'm not gonna have to
tricking you
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I forgot about you don't
get me
don't get me Oh that was too close just
getting me give me this please yeah it's
just straight ahead I am in trouble I'm
in trouble I am in trouble please I just
want how didn't know how you got there
how did you got there you're gonna save
real quick really quick I'm out of a pop
into this thing here I'm going to put
these away and then I'm gonna look at my
map looky and um
holy [ __ ] I'm good I didn't completely
search the records from [ __ ] I need to
move the I need to move I know what I
need to do I need to all [ __ ] I need to
move the UM me go no Marvin please no
Marvin Marvin no Marvin Marvin okay it's
fine because I can cut through here no
problem this is easy this is easy no
problem no problemo
I can cut through here I think there's a
oh
I should have sprayed you oh Jesus
okay not again you bastard
let go of my leg oh you suck oh you suck
so much oh you all sucker you all suck
your this is the wrong way I went the
wrong way I went the wrong way I went
the rod this is wrong oh [ __ ]
just kill me all right let's see how big
guy kills me hey big guy where are you
where'd you go
good guy you in the women's bathroom big
guy Wow
sorry listen listen I thought you hey
buddy you're Big O my sternum hey how
you doing it oh okay that's that's
intimidating I am dead okay hang on most
weapons are but pea shooters before the
mighty tyrant yeah I'm picking that up
I'm getting that did I change out my
inventory no I did not because I am a
fool because I am but a fool I am but a
fool I am but a fool I am but a fool I
am
but err fool okay I am but a fool but a
lowly fool so I'm gonna go to the
library I'm a library I'm gonna move the
things if I have time wish I may and
also which I may not I may not have time
but I'm gonna move some things around
it's gonna be great this is not the way
the library is it oh [ __ ] God saw the
other side ah shitty tits ah you know
what I'm not gonna break because I've
got better things to do with my time
like go down downstairs whereas before I
went up I'm gonna go now go down I'm
gonna go now yeah hello hi how are you
good to hear oh hey friend how are you
oh you look good you guys look great you
guys look really good
no no no no that's I don't know what
that was all about those weird huh those
weird hey clubroom oh my god you
straddle II bastard oh my god oh my god
sexy confiscates report 6:00 to 11:00
okay 6:00 to 11:00
all right 6:00 to 11:00 I got it I know
that I know what that's for oh [ __ ] oh
all right
why they put bullets in the
interrogation room okay whatever box I
know what that's for
I know what that's for I know what
that's for
okay this is good this is good okay I
gotta get out of here okay I gotta get
out of here I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it now my ribs my ribs my
my ribs are nothing but weak babies
before the mighty tyrant
oh my ribs okay it's fine I was just a
little a little bit of a warm pitch but
that's fine cuz I know what to do with
this
Ruby box I need to put a ruby in it all
good
also I know this combination now okay
no.6 hang on mr. tyrant who hang on oh
[ __ ] um there we go okay good great what
is that Oh Matilda gets a muzzle break
whoa good for
no no hey good for you Mathilda good for
you
Mathilda I'm so proud of you with your
extended clip and whatnot and what have
you
hi I'm Marvin how you doing you good
down there you good you good Marv you
could Marv I bet you're good you seem
good
I seem good okay let's do some let's do
some oopsy poopsy x' alright combine
with this BAM
Oh like a thing of well a badge a badge
a badge whose be alright excellent
far out let me combine this combine this
and then let me combine these Oh
suddenly I ain't so wimpy baby I am a
big strong man and I can put this key
away and we're good to go now let's get
to the library let's save let's save
let's save I know we're a little hurt
but let's save okay we need to start
redoing saves all right yeah we do that
baby okay we're good we're good we're
good
okay so I need to get to the library I
need to get by Marvin hey I don't think
he knows where I am I think he's lost
and that's my advantage okay so I can
use this to move the things in the
library yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah use
yeah oh yeah that's gonna be good all
right let's move the
no no no wait no no over one you're
gonna move this over yeah yeah and then
one more from the other side will
complement it all come on leave it there
you go so strong so so strong all right
and then we got it I think that's enough
right should be all we need to get
across here right I'm thinking that's
probably what we need to get across
probably yes
and then whatever the hell is in this
room is mine forever hello Marvin Marv
Marvis Bay buddy up here where the
tyrant can oh how did that not kill you
god damn it okay I'm Matilda you're up
to bat how many bullets can you hold
Matilda okay Oh bang my muzzle break
whoop
there we go muzzle break really gets it
huh yeah Oh Oh hear that oh [ __ ] what is
that the clock this is where I needed to
go I've got a big old piece of clock
equipment repair plan okay
stay the yoke threatening to break
alright but that's okay cuz I've got a
big old gear
I've got a gear I'm a genius
oh [ __ ] oh oh don't have what really
we're just gonna fumble around there
like an idiot like to left-handed fool
Oh over there okay that's probably
that's probably what I need
how about this you go hear that okay
that oh [ __ ]
I think oh [ __ ] oh where to go where was
that where was that where did that
happen ah that's I'm not here I've never
been here I've never been never been her
never been him Oh small gear that's
that's useful this is really useful okay
um I don't know what I do about this I
am I'm so boned why I'm so owned doesn't
know I'm here
it's fading away it's fading away cuz he
doesn't know he doesn't know I'm here
he doesn't know he doesn't know I think
oh [ __ ] he knows he knows now
oh [ __ ] put this in here
okay okay okay okay what did that do I
don't know I don't know what else he
needs another door here oh where does
this go where am I now
oh oh I'm on the backside of oh okay
that makes sense man they're really good
about really utilizing the entire
environment here what is this for pills
gunpowder large oh oh okay good great
good I guess really good in fact
probably okay what I think I need is to
read the repair plan no this doesn't
doesn't help me at all that's not a plan
that's just it's not actually a plan so
what I yeah what happens if i take this
gear okay oh oh it fits
oh oh oh it's just a switcheroo okay I
almost left yeah I was left thinking
that I needed to go do something else
hey 3:00 a.m. oh [ __ ]
did I do that I'm sorry we on you are so
funny and that is the tyrant coming
right at me I need to go I need to leave
immediately because he is oh not there
hahahahahaha hey Don been fooled he
doesn't know where I am
he has no idea where I am or what I am
up to okay oh what's this
aha ok where does this oh oh I know
where this is interesting interesting
interesting ok is this door that's a
heart door ok
that's a hard door this is over here ok
friend back to where I was ish and now
that I have both the lever and the used
Buki what I need to do is I need to
figure out which one I'm closer to I
think I'm closer to the use Buki area
maybe oh it's on the other side why is
everything over on the other side why do
I not know anything dad whatever ok I
got a door to the other side which risks
me coming across the path of mr. fists a
lot on venture Oh Oh mr. fists a lot is
that you hey Leon you might not want to
look behind you
Liana I just want to I just want to let
you know you might you might what God he
hurries up his scooter who knows what
I'm taking my time
ok it's fine cuz I know how to get
around you oh I know oh I know because
you have your shortcuts doesn't mean
that you get to be an [ __ ] about it I
hope Claire's doing ok maybe
Skoosh alright perfect easy easy perfect
easy and perfect perfect and easy
perfect and easy there might be a liquid
if I remember oh no he's dead okay he's
dead that's good then the stars office
was right here the uzbek he goes in
right here right there for the uzbek II
got it easy-peasy I don't know why that
was in some gem encoded [ __ ] but
okay
and hopefully I get a big boom in guard
please give me a big piece out of big
book Oh lightning Hawk I love it not
desert eagle lightning Hawk yeah yeah oh
yeah let's make you okay you're number
two that's not that's not good we need
to make you alright alright okay let us
the stars member how are you all doing
in that drab old station hanging in
there against old irons me just got back
from a hot date with a hot chick but you
can guess will we get up to under her
extra-large
umbrella aha one month is no way enough
to scratch the surface maybe I'll extend
my vacation to another six months Barry
don't even think of coming to join me
wouldn't want to make all the cute girls
cry yeah so let's just leave the babes
to me Jill if Claire tries to contact
you please let her know I'm okay Chris
Redfield Chris what a player the P iymp
Wow Chris that is just amazing
oh do I need the USB key back can I get
it back oh I guess all right then
easy enough but now that I got that I
can pull my big boomer gun bullets out
of the ammo thing and maybe I can shoot
maybe I can shoot Tyron in the face now
maybe I've got something that's capable
of blasting his ass Oh far and away what
if I not looted out of the library down
in the library have I not done searching
that and I tried to find the flash
grenade it wasn't there
all right whatever doesn't matter okay
there's lictors all around but I think
the tyrants coming back the way that I
just came so I'm gonna try to go the
upper path I don't think there's
anything up here then again I might be
mistaken I might be very mistaken I
might be exceptionally mistaken oh no
there's a liqueur up here [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
all right
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm running for it I'm just
running for it just running running is
what I do it's how I do it's how I roll
baby
okay all right great great this is great
this is great
I forgot that her but that's okay I
don't either but I'm doing fine I wasted
the bullet but it's okay Oh like wasting
is how I say hello okay I don't know
what I forgotten in here I don't know
how I could have forgotten anything in
here but apparently I've forgotten
something in here maybe behind the
shelves that I moved maybe maybe behind
this last shelf right no they can't even
let me move it no there's nothing
yeah I'm out of here Marvin hey Marvin
are you doing good to see you how's the
family All Right see ya
take care of yourself yeah working hard
or hardly working hey yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay I'm gonna hold on to that I've
got electronic parts I don't know if I
have enough I've got herbs I'm gonna put
them in I'm gonna use them I guess I'll
use the green green just because that's
probably the least I'm gonna hold on to
it for just a little bit because I know
that I can take just one more hit before
I have to use that but I am gonna take
the big ammo mag ammo I'm gonna try to
avoid using it but I'm gonna hold on to
it just because I can
okay so I've got this lever no the
levers done what do I need to do Nick I
knew I've got the parts okay so I need
to get back downstairs
to the garage do I have enough I've got
two parts I don't know if that's enough
is he near Bobby that music is usually
indicative of him being near me near
Bobby fine polish nearby Oh
that's the way that I was going to go
all right you know what I'm I do gonna
see if this does anything to his stupid
face haha Marv Marv you do not betray me
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] are you moving
[Music]
no not like this part
Oh barb I'm just gonna die because I
didn't want to waste all those bullets
if I didn't need to
hey buddy
hey-ya hey-ya
guess I'm dead alright that's okay
that's okay
switch to assisted mode no no no no no
no no no I don't want to I know what I'm
doing I know what I'm doing here I know
what I'm doing so he's coming in there
so what I need to do is I need to get
down to the basement and I need to see
if this is enough electronics parts
forget what I need to get I also need to
see there's there some areas here that
apparently I have not finished exploring
but I don't necessarily have what I need
so I'm gonna go the generator room how
did I miss gunpowder in the generator
room Oh prolly cuz I was running through
there real fast right okay so let's see
I'm gonna I'm gonna do I'm gonna go to
the basement I'm gonna go to the
basement that's where I'm gonna go this
is a rather backwards way of going down
to the basement but I'm just gonna go to
the bakery hey buddy
hey how you doing and knock your hat off
your head you stupid idiot yeah that's
right I called you dumb idiot what are
you gonna do about nothing go do a whole
lot nothing yeah that's why I thought
stupid fine it's fine it's fine
that's a ha that's a lot of zombies it's
a lot of zombies coming down that
one-way wasted a lot of bullets going
down there but whatever it's all good
baby
I'm gonna get where I need to get okay I
missed some stuff in the generator room
I believe I can't get there from here I
got to go all the kennel ah the dogs I
don't need to go to the generator room I
forgot I don't need it I don't need it I
don't need it I don't need it I don't
need Oh
[Music]
No
okay we're good
screw those dogs I'm a dog guy but I
don't feel like dealing with those dogs
at all in any way what shape or
everything okay let's go let's see oh
this probably food I probably needed
some more than what I have but this is
the best I can do with what I've got so
I at least want to see if this is gonna
help okay um
electronics purred examine oh I need to
help I need to open them right right
wow that's I wonder about this one too
there we go boo-boo all right there we
go
okay so then use and use that's enough
oh it's a puzzle I love puzzles uh hey
there we go okay good I guess that is
all I needed
okay then hopefully the tire doesn't
come back hey buddy sorry I was a bit of
a noose to you
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right well I've got that and
I've got the parking permit garage so I
can get out of here right what are they
after
first they spray I haven't had spraying
so long offends memo the station
swarming with monsters even here I can
hear the cries but it's not the zombies
I'm afraid of codename Tyron the
ultimate bio weapon developed by those
bastards in the utmost secrecy to think
that their that thing might be wandering
around here chances are they've ordered
it to wipe out the witnesses that's real
nice
no ass oh that's fine what am I worried
about oh [ __ ] huh
can I go this way I'm smart I'm smart
I'm smarter than you
I'm smart oh I'm not that smart
oh all right you know what I know I know
what this is for there we go yeah yeah
baby yeah oh gotta pause it yeah okay
whatever it doesn't matter it's all good
no no I can make it I can make it no you
know I don't know how to do anything
about this okay all right I got some
spray I'm gonna spray myself there we go
got some spray I'm good to go oh hey
buddy hey
[Music]
okay okay saving your ass that's twice
you care unless you're keeping score
look this isn't a game
nothing dies down here
yeah yeah and this house hoping you
could explain what's on it maybe right
here it oh yeah that probably important
oh okay yeah you haven't heard it yet
okay makes sense
okay way all right thank you
thank you for the help the assistance
it's a tyrant dad is he dead now has he
gone forever I'd like to believe
okay listen lady you need to you need to
be a little nice to me I have been
through some [ __ ] today and it's my
first day by the way my first day so
little stressful stressed out little
stress
I can't Crouch like you I can't I don't
have a Crouch button weirdly enough
Wow
we're free is that the until you need it
unfortunately no Ben didn't come through
well what exactly are you looking for
more info on that people responsible for
this mess what about you trying to save
the world
I told lieutenant Bren I'd bring help
good luck getting that okay good talk
man you you are known for your riveting
conversation and I'm really happy about
that what is a hole doing in the middle
of the city
why what wait a minute well what do you
do we did I know Oh
convenient a gun shop hello is there
some crazed gun odor in here gun shop
owner someone crazy enough to survive in
this apocalypse hello oh hi ah yeah
peculiar about then okay I guess I'm on
my own then whoa what's that
whoa long barrel what does that mean
what does that do sure oh okay
cool uh handgun ammo perfect always nice
on a rainy day oh I knew it I said don't
move called it I'm just passing through
I'm gonna ask you to lower that weapon
turn around go right back out the way
you came in I think your daughter needs
help sir
tell me how to deal with my daughter
drop it go wait step aside when you
determinate her before she turns it's my
[ __ ] daughter you know just let them
be
come on sweetheart I told you to stay
put
what they did it was
you're a cop you're supposed to know
something how did this happen huh she
was a sweet little angel
[Music]
she's hello
excuse some privacy you know it's one
thing to keep the truth from me but why
him
I want to find out what's happening here
and stop whoever's behind it helping
people like them that's why I joined the
force
my mission is to take down on Bella's
entire operation we may not make it out
whatever it takes to save this city
count me in
and deep sad and deep no boy did he just
shoot his daughter did he shoot the both
of them I don't know and I don't know if
I want to know okay did I get everything
that I need to do in here probably I
don't know if I want that long barrel
extension because I already got a long
handgun not that I know what good it's
done for me but I've got it like what do
what do you do with a long handgun
anyway tonight there was a way to detach
it right remove parts okay I'm removed
that okay so let me examine no not that
let me examine this what does this do
three wraps I don't want three rounds
per pull the trigger I don't want that I
don't want that at all I don't want that
at all oh I would never want that okay
all right well this is fine I don't need
this I don't need I don't need that
that's that was that's a waste of ammo
okay and then what is this long barrel
do it just increase accuracy ups
capacity to eight greater muzzle
velocity less spread makes each shot
more powerful okay now that is good
that's worth it so instead of having a
long boy pistol I'll have a long boy
shotgun and that makes a lot more sense
anyway that makes that makes a ton of
sense makes so much suits always every
time of course
great all right nothing else to say
about that okay thank you I didn't need
to talk about it anyway this whole place
is wonderful and I'm happy about
everything that's happening here now you
talk okay all right sounds the synced I
like it I like clear action I'm all
about that point me in the direction
point me where to shoot I don't want to
do ignore this blight mark on my neck
that's probably not but not bad at all
don't don't even worry about it all
right
is that trench coat weird and
uncomfortable based on what you've said
the server seems fitting mmm after you
gee thanks
yeah thanks I mean it's I guess it's all
the same you go in first me go in first
what does it matter if it's only don't
have a gun to my neck okay whatever
goodbye can't imagine a real scientist
being down here
okay sewers are run by the city how
could they have a facility without the
authorities knowing godom who got him
all right whatever can you just point me
in something there shoot and also I I
still think that I'm somehow gonna get
back to the police department at some
point I know something Claire did I bet
oh god only knows I think I know does
that make me God okay
well that didn't look good but you know
when I was uh don't mind me type in my
memoir here for a second when I was in a
nut in the future in the far-flung
future I distinctly remember punching
some alligators with my bare hands so
I'm pretty sure these guys ain't gonna
do nothing to me
and it's gonna be it's gonna be nothing
for nobody actually all right anyway let
me put this away put this away
um gunpowder I have nothing okay we're
fine oh good hello Wow that is
destructive that is some damage that's a
lot of damage okay you just putzing
around in there what are you doing oh
okay all right well hello don't mind me
anyway I just gotta fall where that big
Gator went you you want to see me
wrestle a gator you'll see me punch an
alligator I've done
before Oh gladly do it again okay all
right lady just gonna be in silence is
really comfortable feel happy about this
anyhoo oh no chance you're stuck with me
to the end
okay whatever why would you want to go
why would you want to go alone anyway in
this nightmare of an organ like
everything about this is horrible why
would you bad idea Oh idea you sure this
is the right way unfortunately uh oh no
no no no wait there no no that's no wait
hang on
oh holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god the exactly
[Music]
Oh Oh my twitch you on that you
overgrown son of [ __ ] good lines man
good lines real tough talk real tough
man I am it's still twitching hang on
okay it's done okay hey hello did you
see that did you see it
did you see it was pretty cool just get
up here okay alright impatient alright
whatever I'm here now
you said the virus turned people into
monsters not reptiles fair point I'm
just impressed you made it in one piece
thank you no I mean I'm an impressive
piece might I say all of me is very very
alligator resistant pretty intense what
you got going on here or is that a
crocodile I don't know I don't know the
difference but you know maybe you do
maybe you do maybe you know so let me
get this straight
umbrella sells monsters like that to who
our military somebody else's they don't
sell the monster
they sell the viruses that make them and
and that is who makes the viruses scary
is that alligator was and that's far
more dangerous I don't think that's a
hundred percent true I don't think I'm
not hundred percent sure I believe that
but okay
all right then whatever you say lady
whatever you say
where you going sorry chief Smith where
we dancing I didn't know which way we
were gone
oh yeah well handy-dandy nope not that
one handy-dandy this handy-dandy
are we back where we started where's a
safe box
okay whatever anything else I've missed
No all right you coming in D coming out
shit-or-get-off-the-pot
stop being a creep oh why are you being
a creep oh you say Stewie why you why
are you being a creep oh are you being a
creep oh okay whatever ah cutscene
identify yourself she's who we're
looking for
not much time
need to dispose of it we're here for the
g-virus that's not gonna happen
I'm warning you doctor oh yeah
Hey
I didn't expect that from a scientist
Leon
forget about me I just go stop her
before she gets away wait
outside the facility pursuit of annette
it's not on her it must be in the nest
once it's in hand I'll call for
instruction all right
it's a lovely dress run Annette but you
can't hide
well um I have many questions and what
is this chicken doing leaping out of its
chest why is there chicken that is the
chicken leaping out of the chest there's
a chicken leaping out of its chest
that's a chicken that's a chicken is a
chicken leaping out of okay whatever hey
Leon he's just taking a nap ski it's
okay I don't need guns you you you okay
all right cool
yeah okay all right sure
uh what are this out of service okay all
right away I go am I in high heels yet
very practical all right I'm like that
lady from Jurassic Park who wouldn't get
rid of her high heels no matter what
okay away we go was sending into the
universe come on let us fight oh okay
that's fun oh okay this is fun
track wiring and hacking electronic
equipment all right
secret weapon - I love it
yeah it is half that [ __ ] pack that [ __ ]
yeah Leon I'm gonna hack your brain oh
you got you Leon ah you got some to hack
we shall get hackable no where's your
hackable you chicken pack that chicken
pack this elevator back the ceiling Oh
hack everything hell okay well why did I
get that spinning why is that why is
that what I wanted a hack this blade too
fast huh who can't beat my hacks yeah my
actions permitted or jet well a hack
complete candy from what baby I don't
see any baby and I see no candy what are
you talking about did you just say in
words to say words I'm a hack the [ __ ]
out of everything in here nothing can
stop my hackings there's cockroaches you
got get hacked under my heels oh yeah
aaaah what do we got going on here huh
hackable I see you get the hack yeah
what else we got going on here is
another hack going off somewhere this
spread baby spend spend a night
Oh probably fine merely singed my dress
hair hack I'll hack you to kingdom come
hack your yeah we go here are you oh you
bout to get hacked - nobody's business
okay wait ham my business my business
can i hack you hack hack my hack your
corpse orna whatever men guess you don't
want to get hacked September inspection
ID wristband okay did you ever wristband
on you I cut your arm off did you have a
wristband okay whatever okay see ya oh
oh did he get back up or whatever don't
matter
I'm unstoppable hack machine oh I spy
with my little eye something that I can
hack that doesn't sound good
all right that sounds oh hey buddy don't
worry about me
all right I'm on the trail all right
come on
hack City USA coming up real hot and
heavy I still don't know what the
hydrants are for they've got to be for
something maybe something to do with
Claire maybe not me all right what do we
got oh come on
oh no that's a bit loud and unnecessary
Wow oh hi jeez and how about you nailed
it
thank you please alright you know you
you know what you need ADA ADA you need
more fanny packs
you need like many many more fanny packs
now you come this way huh oh oh oh you
almost got me you almost got me oh you
almost got me you almost got me too
there you go
enjoy some of that kaboom boom oh there
we go
oh no you how we got him you're making
me look bad I'm supposed to be a
super-secret FBI agent that's for some
reason and address had not 100% sure of
what date I was going on before this but
[ __ ] went bad real bad and then I'm here
in a dress but yeah it's not gonna stop
me from hacking up a storm hey what are
you walking sassy like that stop walking
so sassy okay what do you need former
former best friends here what you're
going on here some there's some unspoken
thing going on here okay
persistent bastard oh hi Hey hi how are
you oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
okay um oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty shitty
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] sit oh [ __ ] my
dick Wow [ __ ] me no please Hana Hana die
I don't know I'm not - yeah I'm too
young I thought I hacked that oh I do
I'm gonna hack you get ready to be
hacked here we have to do a peace pact
ah good I'm gonna go here oh yeah
got a hack hack there we go Jack I
thought I hacked this like to the store
to hack that all right hacky sack hacky
sack get back ow ow
my brains home - brain hi brain whoa
juice all right ow
a lot of Al okay many hours I'm not
doing so good I'm gonna readily admit I
ain't doing the best that I could be
doing and what I what I am doing is not
up to snuff of my normal okay and then
that and then a hacky sack the put it
back put it back put it back put it back
there we go and shut it rip it don't
shut I thought it would shut I got a
father that wouldn't just shut it but no
apparently not okay
yah
oh wow
smooth moves smooth move ada let's brush
something else in there that I didn't
get but smooth move
smooth move all right so uh what am i
doing in here
Oh Andy all right well guess I'm ADA now
good that's what I always wanted
hello hack No
all right good thing there's so many
things to hack in here
I like him this definitely wasn't in the
first game probably I just imagined
technologically the ability to like dive
deep into the walls like this and hack
things probably not necessarily the
thing that we got going on okay new
wristband incinerator uh okay all right
whatever
Curt chunk
[Music]
oh hey do you think I might be able to
get the tyrant in the incinerator all
that be legit Oh that'd be so sick oh
that would be the bee's knees oh [ __ ] oh
my god oh wow
hello oh great oh great
hi
Bravo gonna burn me alive now you'll
never get your filthy hands on the G I'm
not the only one after it you realize
that okay time to get super hacker
skills engaged all right three two one
hack the lure okay here we go okay
where's this going okay um okay here we
go
okay ah that goes there that's good
[Music]
oh oh I know what I need to do oh [ __ ]
oh I know what I needed oh god oh god oh
god okay here we go and one more one
more one more come on please please
please oh my god
made it
nailed it well I guess I won't be using
the incinerator on the tyrant but alas
at least I am NOT burnt to a cruise so
there's that that was way too close that
was unbelievably close that was so darn
close too close okay cool
all right what's over here where am I
treatment pool room what the hell oh
well this looks fun
hopefully Leon's fine if that tyrant
just found her him he's gonna be Wow
ow my eyes why would you do that
no it's cat and mouse game the game is
over you lost
tell me
your husband's still alive
or did you kill him so you can take
credit for cheat
interesting theory my dead body
ah spray something on it use your spray
oh that's probably not good
it's the alligators big brother
Oh Oh a mite nap time over for Leon oh
okay well it was a good nap oh boy
[Laughter]
she doesn't have her trench coat she's
butt naked out there I got a saver I
gotta give her back her trench coat all
right so now we're back in we got all
over equipment again she's in the
treatment pool room and that's all I
know
aw where are you hey oh this works okay
I didn't think this worked
hey des hey des oh hey convenient okay
hey hey hey I'm gonna take this whatever
who cares okay let's move on save a
little bit I guess
and then find a tie I guess where am i
Watergate oh oh I don't to be here oh
[ __ ]
why would I want to go down there yeah I
want to go down there
sploosh hey hey yeah hey des
why am i down here I don't know this is
where I'm supposed to go I don't know if
this is what I was supposed to do I got
a bad feeling about this
yeah Oh God
I don't know where I'm going oh I heard
that oh where am I
why am I here what is that shotgun
shells great love it give me that give
me that [ __ ] give me that [ __ ] no
combine it now you dick there we go
whole areas gross why is this here why
does this exist like this why is any of
this this why could it didn't it be not
this what does it have to be this I
don't like this
hey else okay whatever oh I guess I've
explored everything I need to do explore
hey you are interested Oh weird okay
well these guys are very dead oh hey
how's it going hey how you doing yeah
how you doing okay cool great and
goodbye how you doing
you okay there seemed to be a immovable
object okay
where am I now why did I go that way why
did I do that I don't understand why I
went around that way you know whatever
I'm here now oh hey how you doing
treatment facility oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
alright fine then hello are you dead you
alive Oh Andy
I don't know why that would be the thing
that it would do why would that do that
thing that it just did why would it do
that oh [ __ ]
pardon oh you're okay probably oh oh no
oh no goodbye who nailed you nailed your
baby alright so I got an electrical
socket I don't know why but I got that
is that important what's a good that I
just did what I did or is that getting
in the way of something I'm not a
hundred percent sure like and let me put
it back in real quick
okay so this is here but I still don't
have the key for that you buy a stirred
oh it's another oh I see okay so this
goes somewhere else so I can take that
and put that somewhere else but there
was still place to go okay weird hello
another knife hell yeah oh yeah baby
can I go under there oh I wish I could
go under there if I knew how to crouch
which I don't know alright so where does
this go
good where am I going whoa why I didn't
why did I do that that's not what I
wanted to do oh my god blue herb okay
good because I'm probably gonna get
infected with some horrible toxins down
here good thing I've been stocking those
up oh um no um no no no just
no no no what are you oh my god holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh my god
Oh Oh got it no okay no no
die die can you die
there you go way to take all my bullets
where to take all of my bullets I should
have thrown a grenade I should have
thrown a grenade at it why didn't I
throw a grenade at it I'm an idiot I
don't know I cuz I've never seen one
before that's why I didn't know what I
was dealing with that's why I didn't
throw a grenade at it because I didn't
know it's a perfectly valid reason I
don't need to make an excuse interesting
yeah a little bit interesting you know
why do you ask I don't understand why
I'm here I don't know why I went around
like that I don't know where I'm going
I missed the police department can I go
back to the police department because I
really missed the police department that
was a really nice place and I liked a
lot and it was very comfortable and
familiar and this is where Edith was or
whatever her name is worse nubile very
as where subbu Berry was I remember
where'd she go yeah where did how did
you know she was here in the first place
hmm
okay director Owens there are alarms
going off all over nest I can hear
gunfire with trap situation is dire
contaminated with a virus it's
unbelievable the failsafe I can't stop
coughing you it was all up okay yeah
well all right sure then yeah okay jump
down why don't I cuz that's all I know
how to do apparently we oh boy where am
i this looks clean and nice what uh
what's wrong with it
heydo
I'm coming ADA I'm coming to get you
fairly maybe I don't know maybe I know
if I feel like it or if I have time to
do that maybe I'll do that yeah I'm
coming for ya paid up on the way don't
you worry about things map no thank you
all right whatever I have no idea hey I
can put this tape in here
all right let's see what this does I
remember tapes from Resident Evil 7 L is
very fun
okay so someone scarf down on some virus
those brats spread it oh that would make
sense that makes sense that that makes a
whole heck of a lot of sense that makes
a whole Hoopa T hoop in a lot of sense
okay so there's bullets there bullets
I'm gonna see bullets Oh fine here okay
all right
bullets okay we're good to go ADA I'm on
the way don't you worry I am just right
there pretty sure the rook and Knight
are on the same wall the bishops queen
who couldn't Queen and rooker opposite
each other - what is it wait I lost the
thing that tells you how to unlock the
door
stick one plug in the terminal but if it
was plug it was where please be a pal
and share oh oh oh it's chess no it's a
bunch of chess
okay good great no it's a bunch of chess
okay great okay great easy-peasy okay
doesn't work all right so there's oh
here we go
that's a bishop I know Bishop's I
definitely know bishops all right pawn
pawn plug okay beer we go rook and
Knight are on the same wall on the
bishop queen or urn next to each other
the Queen and rook are opposite of each
other
okay so this is the pawn plug definitely
okay so okay so I don't have all the
plugs so I don't think I can do this
anyway so this is gonna be this is gonna
be a fine the plug kind of thing but I'm
gonna keep one of these just because
there might be another situation where I
need to do a plug thing later on because
it was another plug up above so I'm
gonna keep that in mind as I move
forward probably all right so I'm gonna
circle back and I'm gonna see if I can
find something that I need to find
there's a way out here apparently is it
a map yay I got a map yay yay okay wait
was that video player this is a plug
socket I know
cool got it alright what's out here
hello hey da am I supposed to help
Elliot ADA
I forgot ADA yeah ADA yeah I forgot oh
wow very impressed okay a da hae da are
you dumb coming hang on hold on
something I guess I'll be right there
right uh mm-hmm
all right cool what does that plunger Oh
sick tool love that
oh don't love that that's okay is it so
oh I see that's concerning
okay delivery receipt side of the safe
in chalk heat-resistant safe okay
where is this safe but apparently it's
on the side if I find it safe there's a
combination on the side written in chalk
great good to know glad I know that now
okay what do you got going on oh there's
a safe all right easy enough a safe
written on the side in chalk hey how you
doing buddy you all right there - 12-8
get me easy - 12-8 so easy
Wow it could be even longer and longer
yes please
okay allowing it to be fired and
reloaded in one smooth action oh is that
necessary because I feel like having
eight shots is enough shots and I don't
think I'm gonna be getting more shots
one forget oh really really yeah that's
what I'm saying
come on cheese why waste my oh really oh
my god
that was not worth it I should have
scrapped this and I should just run but
I didn't because I'm a doof and I saw my
bullets but I don't know why let's go
this way
hello anybody down here ada probably not
either
why not hello you scared me what what
duh all right listen buddy listen buddy
oh [ __ ] okay well joy not long lived I
guess American closer I probably
shouldn't be laughing so maniacally at
that but it's just so gosh darn funny I
don't know if it's best to combine those
into the three but it seems like the
three is probably the best to have it go
for right that just makes sense I don't
think anyway you know whatever maybe not
I've never even used one of the three
but I got so many mixtures of them
all right well that's good that mean I
can get back somehow
oh hey another grenade I got three of
them
alright next time I see one of those big
things I'm actually gonna use it but
until then I guess I gotta wander around
being an idiot
alright so this is my way back out there
what is that t-bar handle slot I've got
a t-bar I've got a t-bar oh hello
oh nice okay this time I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna equip you alright I
can't [ __ ] this up I cannot I'm not oh
that's not equipped why is that how do i
oh yes shift wait no [ __ ] wait how do I
hang on well everybody hold on this I
need to remember how do I have okay um
uh oh boy um oh okay
all right hang on oh boy okay how do i
okay gonna notes judgey SH shift control
no space there we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I did it I killed if I killed it good
alright let's put this tea thing here
alright I'm good I know what I do
I'm also very strong Burnley all right
that went just about as good as I could
have ever hoped it could've did I get it
back I got it back okay baby all right
let's get this here good I need these
reload that bad boy and let's make sure
that I have my knife equipped now
because I don't want to accidentally
blow myself Oh all right where we going
now yeah all right this is great this is
great that's not great I don't like you
started ooh fanny pack oh yes please
filled
yes fanny pack yes
this is going so good I am so happy
about everything that's happening right
here I am never been more happy in my
life never been more happy I am so happy
all right let's get out of here hell
yeah where am I now
oh did you just get up alright whatever
oh I can take the peace oh hello
how are you good to see you
oh there's a bunch of you oh great
goodbye forever apparently okay so I am
gonna go back a bit because I want to
see there was another path that I could
have gone that I didn't go and I want to
double-check that way before I go now
because now I've got a t-handle and
maybe it can unlock some other paths or
something hey why why why have you done
this why have you done this why why
would you do this and why have you done
this
oh come on you're gonna go bye-bye
goodbye excuse me okay ah I am so smart
I am so smart I am unbelievably smart I
am big smart my big brain always working
it
please go my big brain always working in
overdrive constantly getting me where I
need to go when I need to get there I am
on a roll I am feeling great I am
feeling fresh give me that key that is
what I need I am doing great this is
going awesome I feel great EDA is
probably dead but I feel so good about
my life all right let me see what's over
here first cuz this seems like a dead
end over here oh that that looks oh oh
no that looks very bad that just that in
general looks very bad
oh but here this looks good what am I
saying pretty good I know exactly how
this game goes now I know what is up and
I can get this no problem all right
was it the last use of that thing no it
needs more uses okay so um should I try
to go down and get that herb or should I
just go this way I'm gonna go this way
I'm gonna oh wait no wait oh it's I'm
back here wait yeah wait a minute
Oh interesting
okay well then let me go back a bit
before I commit to anything else that's
even less good than what I've done so
far I'll go back a bit and then yeah I'm
uh I'm a hop down here real quick it's
probably not gonna be very nice down
here because of all the pulsating organs
I think that's predominant no no don't
no no no okay good oh is this a turd
island turd Boulder a turd Boulder oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh oh my god
right fine bye fine bye 100% a okay
oh I can't go any farther oh I can't go
any farther no I can't go any far
they're okay I need something paints so
like a short stepladder to get up there
I'm gonna move on I'm gonna get back cuz
I don't like this place it's places no
good
maybe I need a tow to like boost me up
there something like that
all right I'm actually gonna go back up
this way and I'm gonna go there was
another way to go
besides this path oh hey how you doing
oh hey um how you doing
don't mind me don't mind me don't mind
me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this was the only way
to go okay
ah [ __ ] all right um how you doing
okay
so I'm gonna get back down I'm gonna go
that way because apparently this is now
the only way to go but this might be the
only way to get back up actually I don't
know if there's any way to get back up
now I really should have gone the other
way because then I would have explored a
little farther but maybe you wouldn't
let me go that way because of that was
the way that ADA when I know this
doesn't make any sense to you what I'm
saying but I'm rationalizing into my
brain so I can kind of get a better
understanding of where I need to go
where I've been you know what I mean
yeah you don't know what I mean but it's
okay don't worry about where does that
go
I'm so confused where just go let me go
up this way I'm a little confused as to
where I've been so ignore everything
that I was saying before because I
actually don't know anything hello I
know I have a key to the tree oh you're
backup okay well that's good to know
I have a key to the treatment room but I
got to remember where exactly I went to
get the treatment room I think I'm going
the wrong way but I may not be oh yeah
that's right this goes back here okay I
need to go here anyway because I need to
get this stuff in the storage okay so
let me put this in storage I don't
really need that I don't think anyway
let me put some of this in there let me
put this in there let me put this in
there let me pull I'm gonna pull this
gunpowder out because I'm gonna combine
this with this yes make big lots of
shotgun shells no we're not gonna store
that keep that I'm gonna put these away
because I don't think I need them for
right now and I'm gonna put the pieces
in here I don't know which places they
go just yet but I'm just gonna pop them
there okay whatever
cuz I need to get another piece before I
do that there's one more piece that I
need maybe two I'm not a harvest insurer
but anyway that is gonna do it for this
episode of resident evil 2 we are making
tons of progress we're doing real good
not great but we're doing good we got
lots of not lots of ammo but we got guns
we got ammos we got kaboom ease we got
progress eight is bleeding to death but
that's okay don't worry about that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
look forward to more videos of this
coming real soon thank you again and as
always
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]